fun really isn't something one considers
we balance the universe
- hey everybody so you requested a new
infinity war video so they've actually
started filming Avengers for now would
they still haven't confirmed the title
of that but we'll talk about that
because remember there was all that Zoe
Saldana business earlier this year where
she referred to it as gauntlet as in the
Infinity Gauntlet can you tell us if
you're in infinity war in the middle of
it I think that the Guardians just
shocked their part when it comes to
infinity Wars like the first part and we
all have to go back for gauntlets later
this year but if you are finding me for
the first time I do Marvel videos every
week be sure to subscribe to get
everything in there will be new giveaway
stuff at the end of the video so the big
thing here is that vision is on set for
infinity war looking exactly the same
way he does in all the movies
meaning that he still has the Infinity
gem in his forehead now if you're not a
big comic book reader in the comics the
gem in his forehead is called the Sun
stone it's more like a solar battery it
just helps charge him but in the movies
he has the Infinity gem Thanos needs
that to finish the Infinity Gauntlet so
the minute they announced that vision
would have the Infinity gem in his
forehead way back during age of Ultron
people were like ooh
r.i.p vision well I guess his days are
numbered because Thanos is gonna need
that gem and will even be able to exist
as a normal person after that like will
Ultron's programming inside of him
reassert itself what's gonna happen
there's just so many questions and even
though they're changing the comics a lot
he effectively gets ripped to pieces in
the comics but the vision character
during the comic book version of the
story just isn't that big compared to
the other characters like dr. strange is
much bigger there's gonna be a whole lot
of changes so once they start dropping
the official trailers we can start
pointing to things like oh hey dope this
is obviously gonna be Spider Man's iron
spider suit his big Avengers upgrade
we've seen the footage that they've
already dropped I've already done a
couple trailer videos for the d23 in the
Comic Con footage so I'll link those at
the end of this but in those you seethe
annos wielding a partially assembled
Infinity Gauntlet so he has the gauntlet
and he has a couple of the gems in it he
doesn't have all of them he wields the
gauntlet grabbing a
I hate chunk of moon and rips it away
from the planetoid and throws it at them
so we're talking Galactus level power we
have since met the black order they've
introduced the children of Thanos as
they're calling them in the movies in
the comics they're just his followers
they're just his elite generals but the
movies making it more like they're his
children in the way that Kimora and
nebula are his children so like during
guardians of the galaxy they talk about
how they used to fight each other every
time my sister prevailed my father would
replace a piece of me with machinery
like maybe if I enhance you you won't be
so weak so he's done that to all these
people
and they posted a behind-the-scenes
video with them wearing their old
costumes so there's gonna be flashbacks
that'll explain what their upbringing
was like when Gamora was still training
with Thanos so it'll probably just
provide some context for the evil
Avengers that he forms around him like
you have the good Avengers that we've
seen in all these other movies now
Thanos has his own version of the Dark
Avengers that he's gonna throw at them
but it looks like it's gonna be Proxima
midnight or even Corvus glaive that's
gonna come for vision to take the gem
and bring it back to Thanos but a lot of
people were watching this happen as it
was playing out like you see vision
looking like he's a human so it looks as
they just play with their comic book
relationship like vision can make
himself look like whatever he wants to
so he's gonna be morphing into Paul
Bettany probably just to bridge the gap
and make their relationship more
possible before he gets his ass handed
to him but if you haven't seen the
infinity war footage they have part of
that fight in there you see a shot of
Captain America holding Proxima midnight
spear so at some point some of the
Avengers come to help him out so if
there was any doubt before now it seems
like it's confirmed that Avengers 4 will
be the continuation of the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book storyline where as
infinity war the movie is gonna be more
like the Thanos quest comic book
storyline so that's just the story that
came right before the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline in the comics so when Zoe
Saldana was like mistakenly saying oh
yeah we go back to film gauntlet the
fourth movie later this year she was
talking about the storyline for the
movie and that might have just been the
working title for the movie because then
supposedly James Gunn came out after
that and was like that's not what the
movies
that's not called Infinity Gauntlet so
we can all theory craft about what
they'll call the movie if they're doing
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline but I
wouldn't be surprised if it has infinity
somewhere in the title Avengers infinity
dot dot dot but I still think that
they'll try to differentiate in some way
from infinity war for the casual
movie-going audience that doesn't
distinguish between a lot of big comic
book storylines like if you saw two
things on a shelf saying infinity war
and Infinity Gauntlet you probably a
little more confused so they might wind
up opting for a title that's a little
more distinct from infinity war but I
really do hope they just call it
Infinity Gauntlet because that sounds
like what the movie is going to be the
cast has been really funny about it this
is the video they dropped right after
they posted all this footage it was like
goosebumps and you see goosebumps and my
characters you know we first saw it a
couple of months ago when we started
working on it today to unveil it and we
had only you know been filming for a
handful of months at that point and
there is something visceral when you see
the Avengers and the guardians and
Doctor Strange and Black Panther and
spider-man all together you just can't
you can't help it and that was the idea
today was to bring that cast out they
were geeking out as much as the audience
was mom was so I know all of you are
asking when are they gonna drop that
first infinity war trailer remember Thor
comes out that first weekend in November
that's probably when they're going to
drop it if not a little bit before then
usually it's the same week as that movie
comes out because they'll probably roll
the trailer in front of the movie in
movies typically don't premiere til
Thursday Friday night but most of you
have probably figured out that they drop
all the biggest trailers on Tuesdays so
if you have anything going on that week
the Thor's coming out I would clear your
schedule just in case that infinity war
footage drops believe all your Avengers
video requests in the comments below I'm
probably gonna do a spider-man video
soon for his iron spider suit that's
what I'm calling it now but technically
it's really just an upgraded Avengers
level suit like it'll be so badass that
it makes the stark tech suit that he had
during homecoming seem like second grade
which i think is holy
because the whole thing about homecoming
is that that suit was super Opie like it
was so amazing that he could barely
figure it out without nedley's help
hacking into it congratulations to the
new Thor ticket giveaway winner Patti
the Pug please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there's a new round in
this video all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber leave a Marvel
related comment I'll announce a winner
when I post a new Marvel video but
there's a new flash to post this weekend
some new Rick and Morty so while you
wait for everything click here for that
infinity war video that I was talking
about and you can click here for brand
new Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight